let's jump to this next story
um about Bud Light because this is big
for the post millennial bottling plants
shut down after Bud Light sales tank
amid Dylan Mulvaney partnership so the
news is
645 jobs lost employees out of work
after the our dog group shut down two
plants according to WRAL it was because
there was a decrease in demand falling
Bud Light sales and thus they had no
reason to make bottles anymore because
Bud Light doesn't need them ladies and
gentlemen
this is winning the culture war and this
is substantive but there was always
going to be Collateral Damage I feel bad
for the people who lost their jobs
because of this but it's it's the fault
of Bud Light well there's also kind of
it's really tragic but there's sort of
the other side of it's not like
America's drinking less beer so maybe
there are 450 or 500 more jobs created
another plant making the bottles and
whole you know but I know the company's
still wildly profitable this is sort of
the same trick that Amazon does it's not
a Budweiser plant it's a subcontractor
so it's a subcontractor that has to eat
all the dirt the bad decisions that the
the contractor made yep
and uh inbev is uh what is it Belgian
Brazilian company anyway so I'm not no
offense I'm not too concerned if they go
bankrupt I mean I'm not all gung-ho on
America right now but I'd like to see
these people go get a job with an
American Brewing Company like Yingling
or something
hopefully if Yingling sails Skyrocket
Molson cores you know whatever then
there will be bottling demand but it's
interesting the point you bring up
people are still buying beer so they're
still they still need to bottle beer so
what's happening these other these other
uh bottling plants are doubling their
workload and these people are getting
laid off not really a great situation
but I I just want to say like
this is actually a sign of permanent
economic damage to a brand that decided
to get woke the damage to the brand
probably can't be overstated can't be
undone either no you could also get a
job with ultra ripe beer I'm not sure if
conservative dads Ultra ride is hiring
at the moment but I'm sure they will be
soon I just drank with six of those I
imagine the police that lost the 500
jobs I imagine that is probably not
strategically located near another place
where these people can just transfer
over to another Brew uh another bottle
you know what's saddest about this is
that these people lost their jobs some
are probably not going to be able afford
their mortgages it's going to cost them
their marriages cost them their children
cost them everything
whereas the CEO of Anheuser-Busch
see he's still employed he still
happened to the guy at the top he's
double breaking it in they're they're
subsidizing a lot of these uh these
companies that would be Carlos Brito as
his name he's Brazilian guy they did can
the CEO of the woman that uh was oh no
no but do you think they're denying it
but it's been reported that her the the
woman uh and the the guy have been like
two people were removed well you know
they got a fat severance package they're
not out on the streets they're not like
these blue-collar people in North
Carolina no no official officially
here's what I think happened officially
they're not fired they're on leave but
uh literally according to sources in the
company they are considered completely
severed from the company the reason
they're not firing them is because
Anheuser-Busch fears a lawsuit they they
fear that they'll get sued some labor
dispute so by putting them on an
indefinite leave and saying nothing
they can get rid of them they're fired
effectively but officially they're not
fired but they're also going to become
folk Heroes on the left they're going to
get a well-paid job with the uh any
number of left-wing groups that are
supportive of what they did so they're
going to land very well I don't have any
doubt maybe but the left is clearly
losing
I mean remarkably I mean this is
catastrophic I think virtue's signaling
loses and it especially loses in
business man when you're all you care
about is making a profit nobody cares
what you think yeah but who's bearing
the I get it and I guess companies are
now a lot more cautious about doing
anything woke right but look at what
happened here and look who actually paid
the price these blue collar workers who
probably vote
the way we'd like them to vote who are
good loyal Americans they're the ones
out of their job the people who are
responsible for the decision they're
getting golden parachutes they're going
to get go work for glad one of the left
wing homosexual groups or something
they're going to do great they should
have quit when this happened so
when the controversy started and you saw
sales declining and the stock was
tanking you've had three months to find
a different job you mean the bottling
Factory people I don't know if it's as
easy for them as we might I didn't say
it was easy I didn't say it was easy but
I get it you can see the storm coming
and I'm sorry I'm not happy these people
are losing their jobs however I am not
going to stand in support of people who
are propping up what Bud Light was doing
I don't think they even had any
awareness of it they're just they're
just shift workers who probably didn't
barely finish high school if anything
like that I don't think they had these
are pure civil like there are people who
know better
I have less sympathy for them the idea
that you okay look what Bud Light was
doing with Don Mulvaney I believe is the
banality of evil the algorithm is
propping up this borat-like character
that is insulting to most people and you
working at these factories and
supporting Bud Light are affect are are
one of the individuals holding up that
machine engaging in the banality of evil
I don't blame people for not knowing
because people try to do good and you
know we try to inform them but I'm not
going to shed a tear if there is an evil
organization doing evil things you are
helping them and then like if if you're
the henchman for a super villain and you
get fired because the villain's been
arrested I'm not gonna be like oh that's
really said he's out of job I'll be like
good less henchmen for the villain I
just don't think you can hold somebody
with like a 90 IQ who's doing everything
they can within the law to raise their
family and has doesn't have the
capability of seeing what you and I can
see because we're in this world I just
they're just innocent civilians that got
caught up in this I I disagree they are
components of a machine that is engaging
in cultural destruction Decay and the
banality of evil the only reason I don't
blame them as individuals for marching
in lockstep with an evil machine but if
we're going to stop the cultural
degradation they have to lose their jobs
but the people who made the decisions
are not punished at all and they're just
going to go on to the next company and
do it again
the the people at the bottom are holding
this machine up I do not believe the
goal is to intentionally hurt the
regular workers but even if you want to
punish them there's no amount of
punishment that's going to make them
understand what they need to understand
to fix this then we're in agreement the
only thing you can do is dismantle the
machine and that means the people at the
bottom are going to lose their jobs
first there's nothing else you can do
you're not you're never gonna get even
if they fire the CEO you're talking
about cutting off the head of a Hydra
two more grow back in its place these
individual workers the bottling plants
that are producing Bud Light and selling
it are generating the profits for an
evil machine you could seize the company
with the government and then a
corporations they're saying that's one
tactics I mean they're just so easily
replaced if they decide oh we're all
going to quit let's move the plant to
Mexico or something like that it's the
next thing it's the people that's not
what happened the demand dropped so much
the plants don't exist anymore which is
good the demand shifted to another brand
somewhere else which may or may not be
in the United States I guess we're
probably not going to agree on this I
think the enemies the snakes at the top
and you just you it's like you can't
hold these people
there it's not even if you want to hold
them accountable you just can't because
they're not capable of being held
accountable like look look you are
correct the problem is the leadership of
Anheuser-Busch Michael Duke have a
standing army in front of them blocking
you from putting in from stopping the
evil practices well I think we've we
succeeded in a way because look these
guys are gonna not make as much money as
they would have otherwise two people who
are pretty high profile kind of lost
their jobs and gonna have a tough time
of it so they and we can see the effect
is because all these companies are so
eager to celebrate pride month you know
regardless what you think of it they
kind of toned it down a little and some
other companies sort of backs up Target
yeah they backed up so to me the the
profits for the people at the top
getting cut is really all they care
about so if you can hit that that's kind
of how you adjust the culture but that
is the collateral damage that will
trickle down and hit the bottom work
well there's a reason it's called
collateral damage right so my point is I
want these people to find jobs I don't
blame them for the actions of the
organization but it is a good thing
there that these jobs were lost
Spotlight shrinking is good that means
people lose their jobs I don't know if
it's corporatism or capitalism that
protects the CEO and the owners of the
company when they're they can just
liquidate their work staff and they
don't have to pay any price for
destroying their company's profits you
would say like that's why communism some
people might want it because the
government can go take the company away
and say you misused it you're gone
that's that's not even communism I mean
there can be Consumer Protections in a
capitalist system we don't strip the CEO
of his job of his duty I mean
stockholders through due process if a
crime is committed well if it's a crime
but since it's not a crime in the
capitalist system we've been letting
CEOs get away with it for years right
how do you want to making is communism
is not the answer no I know that's why
we have a capitalist system and it's
better than communism but how do you
protect the workers all right so you
pass laws protecting workers so like you
can have a capitalist system that says
specifically if you intentionally
destroy the company to hurt workers
there can be some kind of intervention
that it's not absolute there's not
either capitalism or com communism is
not the right word for because it's
political it's not either capitalism or
socialism there's a varying degree
controlled yeah whatever so having
having some protection I think that some
protections are are a good thing but but
ultimately my point here is
what did anyone think was going to
happen you stop buying Bud Light there
is less money going to Bud Light they
will fire many people
we are not mad at the people who got
fired it is a good thing Bud Light is
shrinking that's it yeah and so your
question is how do you solve this in the
capitalist system you know the original
Union organizer who is not a communist
he's an immigrant named Samuel Gompers
had the solution and that was for
workers to form a union and use their
bargaining power to actually acquire the
company since the workers that own the
company so they pull their funds they
buy more and more stock board positions
to eventually a situation where you know
the founder dies and passes on and then
they sell the company to the workers so
when you have a worker-owned company it
provides a lot of protection
unfortunately the union movement of this
country went into the direction of
politics and I aiding politics and
wanting not to take over management but
to fight with management for purposes of
demagoguing and delivering votes to a
political party so that's kind of where
we lost our way but there is a solution
it is fully compatible with capitalism
but also it's a globalist company like
in uh a b inbev is a Belgian is it
Belgian company it's Brazilian and but
uh and so I don't remember where it is
um but so how do our American Union laws
function with a multinational
corporation a union they're still
publicly traded you give that Union that
had the play the people working in North
Carolina or workers Co-op a few board
seats
you'd see a different outcome
they can earn these board seats
so uh and I got some news in this
related area and I I seek advice from uh
our loyal viewers so as many of you know
we're working on a coffee shop and um
there are some issues related to laws
which are causing it to get delayed
massively
it's an old building and so in order to
get it up to code and everything it's a
ridiculous amount of work and it's a
historical building so then there's like
you gotta have a lot of paperwork so
we're looking at we're looking at
Charlestown West Virginia not too far
away from Harpers Ferry and there's a
building for sale it is very big it's
right in this in in downtown and we went
and checked it out very excited and uh
there was a restaurant there very
recently they sold and they moved and I
said how cool would it be to set up one
our first or second location depending
on which gets done first of cast brew
coffee here in downtown Charlestown
we went and met with the uh two agents
our agent and their agent checked out
the whole building it is massive so big
in fact we might even be able to put a
skate shop in the back with a separate
entrance very excited for this there's a
stage that's already there very cool
afterwards we went across the street to
get breakfast and while I was getting
breakfast at a little diner called
Grandma's Diner there was a newspaper
called the spirit of Jefferson in it I
learned that Charlestown passed a pride
month resolution the city council of
Charlestown West Virginia voted to
declare June pride month in support of
all they blah blah blah and long-winded
garbage
and so I said man
what do you do
you invest in a town that is moving in
that direction
or do we make it a point to not invest
in places like this
there's a couple arguments the first is
if we do invest in this town we gain
influence in this town we bring people
to this town employees fans and we start
changing the culture for the better
what if that doesn't work and the town
keeps moving in this negative Direction
and they end up doing things that are
shocking and offensive to our customers
to our friends and fans and we lose that
fight and waste all of our money
the argument against it
is Maybe
maybe the city needs to see economic
Fallout from making decisions like this
so that the people of the town get angry
so I I wonder I kind of lean towards the
best thing to do is actually invest in
the town and buy the business and then
put up flags and signs saying like no to
all of this invite people down and start
shaping the culture with our resources
in force
there is the potential of going to the
city and saying so long as you have this
resolution in effect we will not spend a
dime here I feel like that one doesn't
necessarily work as much it may sound
good but it's like if your money was
never available to the city in the first
place they don't care what you think if
your money becomes available and you say
but I want to see this thing no longer
enforce you actually make a difference
so I'm curious what the people for those
of you that are listening what do you
think is the best thing to do should we
open a shop in Charlestown West Virginia
even though just now in June only a
couple weeks ago five to three the city
voted in support of pride month
which is just so insane as a whole month
dedicated to whatever it is they're
doing
or should we just tell them go to the
agents and tell and say hey
let let the people in the city know when
you when you tell them you can't sell
the building it's because we don't want
to invest in a town like this you know
it's funny you bring this up because I I
your point of view on this is sort of a
um sort of the moral argument of having
the conversation with to see what do you
want to do what consequence you want to
face and I think that the reality is
there's no entity to have that
discussion with and there's no entity
that would react to say losing a
business or entry and actually do these
campaigns all over the country
constantly for other things like uh
somebody wants to build a new super
center for a a big uh like a big box
store right and the community doesn't
want it so I get in and you know either
help them defeat or help them bring it
in or something like that it sounds like
all you really need to do is flip two
city council seats you get a stealth
campaign you find two good candidates
you fund them and you take it over and
you say no more pride month and you know
that's the exact same way the George
Soros took over all these prosecutors
get a stealth campaign get a smart
political consultant recruit the
candidates and you flip it and then you
have but the idea of all I didn't mean
I'm just telling you that's that's how
you maybe something you could do I don't
know
I'm not I'm not that kind of guy I'm not
gonna but it's not even like a stealth
underhanded tactic it's the way of the
world you find people that you believe
in and you elevate them to positions of
power to help lead you and your legal
system who do you think got those five
people that voted for pride month on the
city council people who disagree with
you the issue I yes more so I think the
issue is
the people even though the majority of
people oppose all of that stuff they do
not do anything they don't vote they
don't get up they don't speak out they
complain in private and it's really
really frustrating the idea that West
Virginia the second most Trump
supporting state in in the country would
allow woke prosecutors and they do in
Martinsburg they had a drag show in
public with children and brought them on
stage which is illegal in West Virginia
unquestionably illegal
and no one's doing anything about it and
they all say it's not my problem I don't
I have no Authority sorry I can't do it
the people it's it's surprising a rural
County in West Virginia
voted for woke District woke prosecutors
it sounds like there's a void of
organization in this world and
especially in this country and
particularly in West Virginia but
probably a lot of states that we need to
develop some sort of organization like
we need to if it's just like sorry
little kids on stage with people waving
their junk around out of their face
whatever like someone needs to go in
there and not lay down the law but
create order the average person is still
like learning about this stuff like most
people don't really have a a deep
knowledge about things like queer Theory
and then you've got but
well good well you've then you've got
like the whole like half of the the
country feeding a narrative that this
isn't about trying to abuse kids you got
the whole media establishment trying to
convince people that this isn't about
trying to indoctrinate kids into a
political mindset but you don't need to
understand anything about queer Theory
to be like hey that child on stage
taking his clothes off for money is a
very bad thing
well look the reason this is Advanced as
far as it has is because the left is
well funded and well organized flipping
these back the other way Martinsville
Martinsville Martinsburg Martinsburg
even Charleston West Virginia it wasn't
like Charlestown Charles Charlestown
yeah it's not it wasn't an eight to one
vote it was a five to three that means
look if we can just get the right people
informed and turn out to vote and it's
not that hard it just takes organization
a little bit of funding and it it's not
that hard well I was like you know I was
talking to the agent
saying like I'm not sure it's it's a
good idea to invest in a town that wants
to go the direction of Bud Light clearly
we are seeing a major backlash to what
Bud Light Target Starbucks and those
other companies have done to the tune of
tens of billions of dollars
and I'm supposed to invest my money and
start my business in town that's going
that same direction well here's the
problem though eventually you're going
to run out of places to escape from so
you have to pick a place to make your
stand and fight and you know this is a
place where I think
uh an end if somebody as smart as you
could come in and apply the right
pressure and become part of that
community
I think you could flip it and you you
may just be the person that could do the
degree of pressure I would exert is
talking about it on this show having
events at our coffee shop with comedians
putting up Flags in the window or
something that may be all it takes to
find the additional Community organizers
to go out and go hit doors and explain
it because most the voters who even
voted for the five people they probably
didn't even know that they voted that
way thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time